let's get back on the phones a lot of
people hoping to talk to me at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 let's go next to where do we
want to go there's just a lot of
interesting phone numbers here why don't
we go to the 2:00 to 4:00 area code
who's calling today from 2:00 to 4:00
hello David yes who's this hey Steve I'm
actually in West Virginia the area code
is Chicago but obviously and my mom I'm
a longtime viewer first time I'm
actually calling in and I'm just
wondering just as a lead up to this have
you seen this video that circulating
social media right now what what would
they they call themselves Patriots
but they showed up at an anarchic
communist type of book fair and had
masks on kind of an to the style and
we're basically they're trying to
intimidate ya the leftist now I don't
know do you think that angela is like
then I meet its match soon our people
are gonna start probably is there gonna
be a civil mass civil wars extreme but
they're gonna start getting violent
between the radical right and the
radical west in your opinion listen aunt
is so foreign to me it's match
yeah and Tifa is so small that for
antifa to meet its match it would be
like it's like 20 dudes I mean I don't
even I don't even know it's just the the
my view on this is that there are all
sorts of different actors in the
political space that are willing to
commit physical acts of violence to try
to make political points or achieve
political goals the vast majority are on
the right pointing you know what the
what about aunty for stuff I find two
basically big picture be a distraction
no serious leftists that I know are
advocating for you know violence against
people and I feel like the entire thing
is just a massive distraction I haven't
heard about this particularly you're
talking about these people that are fake
rightists maybe or I don't know don't
see it I I promise you'll probably see
it as you watch political stuff all the
time the Pam Facebook but yeah it's all
it
Varian to stay on and on just times are
tough they just don't when I agree that
no one should be resorting to violence
and you know peaceful I wanted yeah I
just wish that the writing could unite
against the common enemy which i think
is the US government and the insurance
companies and yeah all the government is
the enemy I think you're gonna draw all
the government has been co-opted by
corporations I'm not so you know saying
the government is the enemy is a little
bit too like a narco libertarians matter
and extremists thing but the government
has definitely stood aside as
corporations basically dictate policy
yeah fair enough all right thank you
great to hear from you appreciate it